arenas is a new permanent mode in apex
legends the mode pits two teams of three
against each other in an elimination
style race to win three rounds
but you'll have to win by a round lead
of two to secure the dub
or you'll find yourself in a sudden
death round with chaos everywhere you go
put your prayers to the rng gods away
because there's
no looting necessary here instead at the
start of each round you're given a
select amount of materials that can be
spent to buy weapons
healing and ability uses the amount of
materials you receive increases each
round and you can get even more by
securing kills
or accessing canisters around the map
one canister gives each person on your
team
200 materials which could be the
difference between having no nomag and a
white mag on your gun which
we all know makes a major difference one
person can pick up the materials for
your entire team
but unlike in br once the canister is
used it can be used by the opposing team
that round
each kill is worth 75 materials so
having those extra materials for future
rounds can be
huge for closing out those close battles
only abilities and unspent materials
carry over to the next round
ultimate abilities cannot be purchased
before round three and can only be
purchased every other round
after you first buy one there are some
amazing ultimate combos to try like
valkyries and revenants
so go ahead and coordinate with your
team on when you're buying and using
those ultimate abilities for maximum
effects
unlike similar team deathmatch games
like rainbow six siege
and valorant there is no additional
objective to pursue each round like
disarming a bomb or capturing a flag
you just have to be the last team
standing and though you can revive down
teammates there is no respawn like in
battle royale
with no option of coming back you'll
have to find strategic ways to approach
each fight we already mentioned the
materials around the map which are worth
prioritizing if you want to spin big on
a future loadout
but if you're the type of player who is
always mindful of the ring in br
then you're in luck we may be in a small
arena but we can't escape the ring
so the rng gods are still kind of in
effect because you have to hope that the
ring is going to close in your favor
the rain can appear in various locations
throughout the match typically changing
for each round
moving the point of interest to
different areas around the map so each
round will always feel
a little unique alright alright it
wasn't exactly the whole truth that
there's no
looting there are healing resources to
be found in loot bins around the map
plus a single care package will drop in
a random spot midway through each round
delivering weapons and additional ammo
you can get a mozambique or p2020 for
free 99
so if you want to cash out on grenades
or abilities and roll the dice on
getting a weapon and other resources via
the care package or lubins
then that's another strategy too arenas
launches with
five maps consisting of new additions
and isolated points of interest from the
three
br maps the two new additions are party
crashers and phase runner while the
familiar three pois are kings canyons
artillery
world edges thermal station and
olympus's
golden gardens i appreciate the way
party crashers introduces a new map
while giving us a sense of familiarity
with mirage's boat being the life of the
party
as always so now that you get the gist
here are some general tips to help you
hop into arenas assuming you've played
apex legends before
beware of the peak wars resources are
scarce and if you get cracked early
that's going to leave you at a huge
disadvantage for the rest of the round
this makes characters like rampart
particularly devastating in arenas
when you thirst an enemy they will drop
a few resources
it's not always optimal to finish off
the kill mid-fight
but if you're really running dry on
heals just keep that in mind
while you do have to buy your abilities
legends like crypto who can recall their
abilities will be able to use it again
on a single charge
if you're like me you've become a little
bit reliant on the compass in vr to
communicate with your team but currently
in arenas there is
no compass so be prepared to adjust your
callouts
and mash those pings and the last
and biggest tip of all have fun this is
a brand new mode that is definitely
gonna spice things up and a great time
for you guys to hop back into apex
legends
especially if you've been away for a
while and now that you know a bit more
of the details
i want to know what you guys think is
the craziest ultimate team combo that
we're gonna see
once arenas is finally here so go ahead
and let me know down below in the
comments and of course
leave a like and subscribe to gamespot
for all the latest and greatest in your
gaming news and
more i'll go ahead and see you guys next
time but
play apex and have a good one peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you